it was a lovely early summer morning the Sun rose
at 5:37 but you never saw the sunrise the birds
sang but you never heard their song you were too
busy sleeping gee but it was wonderful to be able
to sleep late and all because of that rectangular
sheepskin in the frame on the wall Vietnam that
Helen Craig having successfully completed a
four-year commercial course is hereby awarded
this diploma with all rights a pertaining thereto
all right a pertaining thereto the right to sleep
as late as you pleased to go are you pleased
the movies rowing in the park when you please
suddenly you woke up while the cobwebs cleared you
tried to think why that ol alarm clock
was set for seven o'clock seven o'clock
that was alright when you were going to high
school but those days were gone forever it
tried to go to sleep again but the Sun
and your conscience wouldn't let you
then you remembered that was why the alarm
clock went off this morning this was the day
you were going down to the telephone company to
see about a job and you wanted to be there early
you picked out your best dress got yourself
as pretty either could and started for the
telephone company's office you were on
your way to what might be your first job
good luck Alan but you will
marry Anne Hubbard had a job
a good part of the efficient operation of the
company you worked for rested on your shoulders
yet you liked people like being with them like
talking to them and your job didn't provide
you with any of that one day you decided you'd
get a job that offered you some of those things
you Fran Gibson start drinking your
coffee that morning with the paper
in front of you you'd worked hard and long
for three and a half years doing work that
not many men had the patience to do one
day there wasn't any more of that kind of
work you found another job but somehow it
didn't give you the feeling of being part
of something that you had before well
maybe this time it would be different
this time it was different
you will carefully interviewed
carefully tested
and given a physical checkup finally of all the
girls in the reception room this morning one in
five of you was hired proud you have a right to
be proud you've been chosen for an important job
in the community by an important part of the
community the telephone company you'll be well
trained well paid and provided with excellent
working conditions so far by our standards you
seem to have what it takes to be local operators
their job is to put through nearby cold or what
these girls are told operators they put through
long distance cold maybe we'll be information
operated did you ever have to make an important
call and couldn't find the number you dialed or
asked the information and an operator like this
bill helped you with your call no matter what
type of work you start with you'll find people
all along the way who were willing and eager
to help you it was that way when I came to the
telephone company and that was a 1904 years back
than I care to own up to it's been that way ever
since I can remember the old timers and they're
not so old timers giving a helping hand to the
new timeless it's part of the Belle tradition and
you would help to keep that tradition alive when
tomorrow's crop of new operators arrive in order
to prepare you for the day when you'll consider
yourselves veterans we're giving the best possible
training courses your supervisor will teach you
all she knows about operating and that's plenty
so in time when you are doing the job on your own
you'll be able to operate like Kathryn Connors
it takes time but you'll be able to do
it now Catherine Connors may look like
the star of this show and it's perfectly
natural for anyone to think so but I'll
tell you a little secret Catherine Connors is
only as good as the girl on either side of it
as good as the girl she's working
with on the other end of the line
as good as the installers
who put in the switchboard
the linemen
the bill clerks who send out the bills
and the tellers who collect for them
as good as the people who make the equipment
and the people who supervise its use in
other words Catherine Connors is part of
a team when your turn comes to take your
place at the switchboard you joined the
team that's providing not touchdown for dear
old high school but service for the public
see those signals light up that's the customers
way of saying they want our help to put through
their call a good part of the success of our job
is measured in terms of how long it takes captain
Connors to answer those signals another way of
telling how well we're doing is found in the
manner in which captain assists our customers with
their call Catherine Connors personifies what we
like to call the spirit of service as a short way
of saying what these girls are doing today giving
speedy accurate courteous service to the public
Jesse Newcomb five years not only performing a
job hazel Morrison three years but really doing
a job darzee Gordon 12 years and sticking to it
every day of the week Esther Johnson three months
every week of the year think back if you can
how often you've waited more than a few seconds to
the operator for any call you've ever made or how
often you haven't received courteous treatment
from that operator not often I dare say this is
the stewardess service of which you've become
a part this is a part of both our jobs yours
and ours each day when you take your place at
the switchboard and the signal lights come on
visualize if you can what lies beyond it beyond
each glowing light beyond the wires under land
overlaying wherever they leave the
good news bad news glad news sad news
yes this is mr. William Redfield police
department but I don't yes I'm Doug his
license number for six to three bright
and white kind of a mixture names trigger
he's flipped out of the house this
morning I'll be right down again
a truck
it didn't start with Diddy
instantly huh that's good
poor trigger
I want to talk to mr. Sam Redfield
Hotel Jackson Jackson City
hello yes as a mr. redfield speaking hello
hello Marian hello Stan getting ready to
come home just about there Dan triggers being
run over Oh No and Billy is taking it pretty
hard I wonder if you'd talk to him sure put
him on Billy Billy there's a call for you
hello Billy mother has been telling
me about trigger now don't worry
about it son we'll get you a new
trigger a big one how's that small
then look son suppose we make it a
puppy a real live puppy all right
now don't cry son we'll take care of
everything when I get home okay by some
and four cans of number two pairs I'll get this
order to you right away mrs. Atkins thank you
but does she have any pain any
nausea well I'll be right over
mr. Johnson I'm afraid it sounds
like more than an upset stomach
it was wonderful party Brava oh and
thank you for the wisp watch is the honey
if I'd only taken that train
yesterday I'd be with her now
it's close to 25 years ago how could I know the
planes would be grounded today I can't believe
it's that long seems like yesterday oh damn for
god sakes come out of that dream world things have
changed this is today that's one thing that hasn't
changed 25 years ago they were calling me to go
ahead son answer you've been waiting all night
for it to ring hello yes this is mr. Fitzgerald
Oh wonderful wonderful so Mary I'll
take the first train in the morning
well then I hate to contradict you but things have
changed in 25 years this one's a girl hey where
are you going I'm going to tell your mother to put
some pink ribbon on those booties she's knitting
good news daddy sad news bad news
I'm at this gym we just buried us we can do
Plutarco
this is all a part of the America that lies
beyond the signal lights of our switchboard
this is a part of a way of life that
Alice MacDonald Jean blubber Joan Rossetti
Hilda green selphie Sikorsky
Martha Taylor and all these operators have made
possible with their spirit of service this is
the public service that all America expects
of all of us 24 hours a day 365 days a year
this is a part of the way of life that you marry
in Hubbard new friend Gibson you Natalie Ellis
you haven't rage and all you soon-to-be operated
we want to continue with your spirit of sis